a big weekend coming up for you this
weekend yeah I got a little pop-up at um
Desto store yeah for my um exotic pop
it's like exotic pop meeting free
mixtape release uh just a four in one
type of thing you know what I'm saying
quick meet and greet type just want a
soda all right got some merch well you
still have like if you have a you had a
water that was your own water that was
out yeah the water that did kind of good
and now it's the soda what's the flavor
of the soda French vanilla french cream
vanilla type so it's like vanilla ice
cream kinda
um
for the mud sippers you know I gave
something for the month sippers to
cleanse themselves yes and get them
demons off so it's a good combination
yeah you gotta get one in one you gotta
you can go cool cup cool cup okay our
dub pina colada you know I've never I've
never sipped the mud
don't try again it's good and it's
addicting I've heard it's very addictive
have you ever tried to get off of it I
literally just got off it for a month
and
three weeks was it rough
no because you know after the first
little four days you know so during okay
that four days is it like withdrawals
throw up you throw up okay I just throw
up that's it so you'll be [__] only for
like one day though okay I Gotta Throw
it once [__] yourself look at my stomach
be [__] up so I can't eat you can't
eat before yeah that's just me well
that's good though you could lose a
little weight because I'm sure the lean
had some wings I'll be knocking [__]
back
smacking [__] make you eat too soon and
you drink tons of soda yes that's a lot
of sugar cleanse myself with that holy
water man have you ever tried to sip
lean with diet soda
I don't think it's gonna give it the
same like smacked like a Diet Sprite
yeah I mean like you know
that could be a Vibe I feel like it's
like the healthiest way you could do it
you're right the healthiest way it's not
healthy let me be clear how to sound
kind of like smart but it is smart
because what because most people who
have lean gut it's because they just
drink soda all [__] day yeah Sugar
Sugar [__] that Diet Coke got zero
calories that Diet Sprite Zero calories
you might have to try it out with this
nah I think that's gonna [__] I think I
tried it on an accident one day and it
was like
not it cause it get a Diet Sprite ain't
got enough sugar Diet Sprite no no it
tastes like their sugar it's called
aspartame
bro especially for somebody who drink
this all day you're gonna know us
immediately well obviously this is a
coffee Yeah Yeah from 7-Eleven yeah they
got good coffee you know good coffee
yeah shout out to the 7-Eleven
um what's been going on man obviously
you you just put is the deluxe to your
uh project out the 35 song joint or is
that what's up
the 12 songs that was already okay
is dropping on us like it in there two
for one type [__] like I mean I saw you
have there's 35 songs yeah 35 but you
basically get the listen to the song
that's already out right now so that's
how I think it's out that's like a
triple pass bro but on the first one I
had 32 so I had to add three more only
reason why I did it like that because
when I made the hard copies you can only
do 31 songs well I think it's a certain
amount of minutes a certain amount of
minutes before you have to print two
discs exactly so I reached the minute so
I'm like all right [__] take a song
about type two uh I saw like was it last
year or was it earlier this year you had
teased the possibility of a deluxe of uh
you and Draco [__] no it's still coming
it really got pushed back because uh the
legendary tape had dropped
of course of course of course how is
it's got to be nice to have a guy like
Greedo home right yeah hell yeah we did
a cool video too that's all day yeah
that [__] was crazy it's a
little AI little effects and [__] have
you guys uh talked about doing a collab
project maybe you know what greeters the
work is easy we just get it in type [__]
I feel like he's got like that like high
output like yeah just like you and your
brother have like that's him and catch
you just like who I got it from just
that crazy out like output of just
like I remember like I was talking to TK
and I was like how many this was like
maybe last year I was like how many uh
Greedo songs he's like bro there's like
a thousand and it's over about that it
was a thousand before he went in so yeah
well cause like he was recording like he
wasn't gonna get out for a very long
time so it's like you know you got to
keep keep up the output like and he was
dropping in videos I remember I went to
the studio one day at around the studio
that [__] did
15 songs the next day shot 15 mini music
videos I'm like this [__] on some [__]
right now well every time I see you you
always have your videographer with you
is that something that you kind of
learned from being around those guys are
just because you're very on point with
your visuals I kind of like Incorporated
that like a year after what 2021
yeah it's like I've been trying to do it
but I couldn't find like the right
cameraman that was just like you got
yeah Cameron they gotta know what's up
yeah I mean [__] cameraman low key would
be [__] security guard too you gotta
make sure your cameraman ain't no [__]
so you can't be you know you're gonna
get robbed of this [__] camera
that should be happening
[__] happens
that'd be incredible videographers be
getting hit up bruh
I just had a homie go to the bay and he
lost all his [__] because he got bipped
yeah that's [__] up it's crazy man
um so for you uh the Exotic pop the
water wasn't with him this is a you know
it was within so okay so this is your
first soda though yeah this is my first
soda and there this is exotic pop that's
not the same company that's not rap
snacks I'm thinking of this coming out
of cops out here exotic pop Texas I
think they got raps next to it if I'm
mistaken they got rap snacks so it's out
of Pop's Base in Texas yeah did you go
out there did you like how does this
work do you like try flavors do they mix
it up and like you're like I like that I
like this you know you just say I want
french vanilla figure it out pop man the
good one you let me see yeah that one
type [__] you know I mean them shits is
everywhere now I was just at a store and
I saw Mac Dre soda yeah they got
actually like a peach [__] vanilla
type can that's like this big the image
is fire but if you want to post some mud
in the [__] You Gotta Buy like
three or three folding [__] all that
sugar and then they like ten dollars a
piece so you're gonna it's gonna have to
cost too much so
um the last time uh you came on the show
you brought uh the otm guys no they're
not seeing too many more is this correct
no they just owed to him you know is it
all is it positive is it negative they
went their separate ways or sidewalks
you know so there's no it's no animosity
no they just didn't
continue the business that was already
on the floor you know